[Música]
varias explosiones se escucharon en la
capital de ucrania kiev según pudieron
confirmar a france24 nuestros
corresponsales en terreno el hecho se
registró a la misma hora que el
presidente ruso vladimir putin anunció
una ofensiva a gran escala sobre ese
país tenemos reporte de nuestros
enviados especiales
los líderes de la unión europea se
reunieron de manera extraordinaria en
bruselas allí acordaron un nuevo paquete
de sanciones financieras a rusia el
proceder comunitario en el conflicto y
la acogida de las personas que huían de
la guerra
el presidente de ucrania volodymyr
selenski lamentó en un discurso
televisado que occidente haya dejado
sola a ucrania agregó además que ya son
137 muertos por la ofensiva rusa
bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
france 24 6 rodrigo sedano y es un gusto
acompañarlos el mundo está expectante
sobre el avance de las tropas rusas
hacia kiev el equipo de france 24 en
ucrania pudo escuchar varias explosiones
y a lo largo del día hubo ataques en
diferentes puntos estratégicos del país
veamos en este mapa los principales
puntos de conflicto las regiones de 'don
y exit lugares fueron blanco de
múltiples ataques ataques también se
reportó que en las cercanías al
aeropuerto de mariupol impactaron
misiles procedentes de la zona de donges
la ciudad de nitro en el centro del país
también fue blanco de ataques y jarkko
fue prácticamente rodeada por tropas la
ciudad portuaria de odessa al sur del
país también ha sido blanco de ataques
mientras que hacia el oeste lutz
llegaron tropas provenientes de belarús
conectamos con nuestra enviada especial
y en el sabio que se encuentra en kiev
irene que ha pasado esta noche tengo
entendido que habéis salido del búnker
en el que estabais habéis salido del
sótano que nos puedes contar que ha
cambiado ahora mismo en la capital de
ucrania
sí es cierto este a las cuatro y media
más o menos este bajamos en el refugio
antiaéreo porque oímos una exclusión
bastante fuerte
en estos momentos en cambio la situación
afuera en la calle es más tranquila por
lo que hemos decidido volver a la
superficie también para poder
conectarnos y estar en contacto con
ustedes
tenéis previsto ir en es salir a la
calle salir a reportear lo que está
pasando en la capital ucraniana o por
precaución tenéis que mantenerlos dónde
estáis
de momento es todavía de noche y hay
toques de queda así que no vamos a salir
saldremos cuando se necesitan las
condiciones de seguridad cuando se
salga el sol y pues estamos cumpliendo
de hecho con las instrucciones que nos
han dado desde el gobierno
hasta que ahora no se puede salir a la
calle y ha dado el gobierno durante
estas últimas horas alguna nueva
instrucción han dado datos de lo que ha
podido pasar en la capital del país
si han confirmado un ataque sobre la
capital del país no está claro qué tipo
de ataque ha sido aún lo que hemos visto
en imágenes que se han retransmitido que
han retransmitido
desde la parte ucraniana es ha sido un
vehículo
un helicóptero quizás que se ha
desplomado sobre un barrio
a los suburbios de kiev y se puede
confirmar que ha funcionado el sistema
antimisiles de la capital se han visto
algunas imágenes pero desde acá no
podemos confirmar nada no sé si ustedes
tienen más información no la verdad es
que estamos en la misma situación que
ustedes este la parte ucraniana dice
efectivamente que este que se han
derribado
y misiles procedentes de las fuerzas
rusas pero la verdad es cierto es que en
este momento no podemos confirmar esta
información
irene muchas gracias por este reporte
esperamos que os encontréis bien que
sigáis bien en la capital ucraniana y
nos mantendremos informados de lo que
sigue pasando allí recapitulemos ahora
algunos de los hechos sucedidos en la
jornada de esta invasión militar rusa
preparamos este mapa para mostrarles los
puntos de entrada de las fuerzas rusas
al territorio ucraniano en el norte
cerca de kiev a 160 km de la capital
llegaron tropas que se desplazaron desde
belarús tropas que permanecían allí
realizando ejercicios militares desde
kursk el territorio ruso llegaron
algunas tropas que lograron acceder a la
ciudad de hardcore la segunda en
importancia de ucrania al este tenemos
las regiones de don y exit lugar desde
allí se esperaba que se movieran tropas
rusas hacia el centro de ucrania algunas
fuerzas se movieron hacia el sur hacia
el mar de azov donde está el puerto de
mariupol muy importante para la región
de don y ex como acceso al mar negro
mientras que desde la península de
crimea se desplazaron tropas hacia el
sur de ucrania
para analizar las posibles consecuencias
de este ataque contamos con la presencia
de manuel alejandro ryan analista
internacional especializado en
resolución de conflictos y profesor de
la universidad externado de colombia
señor reirán contrariamente a lo que
había dicho vladimir putin de que no
buscaban ingresar a kiev estamos ante la
confirmación de que rusia quiere invadir
ucrania
sí muy buenas noches de rodrigo y creo
que en efecto los hechos más que los
discursos hoy determinan lo que se está
registrando para los libros de la
historia realmente creo que rusia ha
jugado en un segundo escenario su primer
escenario era simplemente tener una
influencia dentro de la región intel con
paz pero ya en este segundo fase que él
consideró que es un nuevo escenario de
parte de rusia en este lo que apunta es
no solamente derrocar el gobierno es el
insee sino creo yo en últimas lo que
quiere generar es una humillación al
presidente y mandar mensaje un sitio
bastante fuerte como ustedes bien ha
dicho excelentes que ha dado un discurso
en el que se en el que dijo que se
siente que occidente ha dejado sola a
ucrania que análisis hace de esta
conclusión a la que llegó el mandatario
sí bueno desde hace varias semanas el
occidente ya le ha mencionado al
presidente celeste que no iba a contar
con hombres si los iba a tener bastante
respaldo en términos de capacitación
militar y de armamento pero desde un
inicio occidente había mencionado que no
vio a poner hombre sin horno no puede
poner hombres en tierra porque ucrania
no es parte miembro de la otan y
claramente los países miembros no van a
arriesgarse a atan a tal atracción
porque esto podría también aumentar las
tensiones con rusia de igual manera creo
yo que es una manera prudente por parte
de occidente actuar en la mediante si
responde de la misma manera militar
hacia rusia consideró que las tensiones
pueden escalar y la guerra puede ser
agravada y de hacerse rusia con kiev
cuáles podrían ser los siguientes pasos
de putin y qué escenario podría haber
abrirse en las relaciones
internacionales
excelente pregunta rodrigo genio en mi
opinión creo que existen tres tres
escenarios el primero es que caiga el
gobierno es el inss que y el gobierno
ruso promueva un nuevo gobierno con las
fronteras ucranianas pero claramente es
el nuevo gobierno este o sea de una
inclinación más pro rusa el segundo pues
digamos que quiero yo que ese es un
objetivo minimalista por parte de moscú
y eso iría en ratificar la influencia de
rusia en ucrania el segundo escenario
consideró que iría más que todo que
ucrania sea anexada por rusia y que
claramente ese tendría un objetivo
mediano en términos de lo que podría
lograr rusia en medio de esta falta de
respuesta también de occidente y el
tercer escenario que creo que es el
menos probable y espero que no suceda es
que no solamente rusia se anexe krumm y
ucrania sino que moscú decida invadir
otros países como los países bálticos
estonia letonia lituania y que allí sí
podríamos ver una mayor agresión una
mayor respuesta por parte del 7 porque
estos países se hacen parte o son
miembros de nota señor reirán muchas
gracias por este análisis realmente
interesante en las tres opciones que nos
plantea vamos a pasar a ucrania porque
previamente el presidente ucraniano
volodymyr selenski afirmó en un discurso
televisado en el que apareció con ropaje
militar que ya son 137 muertos por la
ofensiva rusa y que la información que
maneja a su gobierno es que él es el
objetivo número uno de la ofensiva que
según sus palabras pretende destruir a
ucrania al destruir al jefe de estado
pese a ello afirmó que ni él ni su
familia abandonaran la capital del país
de lenski lamentó que occidente los haya
dejado solos escuchemos sus palabras y
hacerlo
weening un tweet sentí hoy pregunté a
los 27 líderes europeos y ucrania estará
en la otan pregunté directamente todos
tienen miedo nadie responde pero no
tenemos miedo no tenemos miedo de nada
no tenemos miedo de defender nuestro
país no tenemos miedo de rusia no
tenemos miedo de hablar con rusia no
tenemos miedo de hablar de nada de
garantías de seguridad para nuestro país
no tenemos miedo de hablar de
neutralidad no somos miembros de la otan
en este momento pero qué garantías
obtendremos y lo más importante qué
países nos darán esas garantías y pues
pec
información según la información que
tenemos el enemigo me designó como el
objetivo número uno mi familia el
objetivo número dos quieren destruir
ucrania políticamente destruyendo al
jefe de estado como un script
también hay información de que grupos
enemigos de sabotaje entraron a quiere
así que le pido a la gente de que tengan
cuidado respeten las reglas de toque de
queda
me quedo en el barrio del gobierno junto
con todos los que necesitan para que el
gobierno central funcione
entretanto en bruselas se celebró hasta
la madrugada una reunión extraordinaria
del consejo europeo con los líderes de
los 27 estados miembros de la unión que
contó también con la presencia de la
presidenta de la comisión europea ursula
von der leyen en ella se acordaron las
nuevas sanciones económicas para rusia
escuchemos
en 2022 en el corazón de europa el
presidente putin ha traído de vuelta a
la guerra a europa watch europa world
count que vamos a hacer al kremlin
responsable el paquete de sanciones que
aprobamos esta noche demuestra eso y va
a tener un impacto máximo en la economía
rusa y en su élite se compone de cinco
pilares el primero en el sector
financiero el segundo en el sector
energético el tercero en el sector de
transportes el cuarto en el control de
las exportaciones y el veto a las
exportaciones y el quinto las políticas
de visas por su parte el presidente
francés en su calidad de presidente del
consejo de la unión europea dijo que
consideraba útil mantener abierta la
puerta de diálogo con el presidente
vladimir putin
letonia sin turistas odias los tiempos
trágicos de la historia han regresado la
guerra está en nuestro suelo y si fuera
necesario demostrar que europa no es
simplemente un mercado de consumidores
sino una potencia que debe pensar en su
independencia energética su transición
climática por sí misma que se debe
pensar en una europa de la defensa capaz
de proteger sus fronteras y a sus
ciudadanos y de proyectarse a sus
aliados se situé ya habló también joe
biden quien aseguró que putin eligió
esta guerra y ahora él y su país
asumirán las consecuencias sin embargo
no ordenó sanciones personales contra el
mandatario ruso pero sí contra sus
posibilidades de comercio y de
adquisición de tecnología para evitar
que siga creciendo el ejército ruso y
estamos en un consenso completo
limitaremos la capacidad reducida de
hacer negocios en dólares euros libras y
yenes hemos congelado el banco ruso más
grande que tienen al menos un 30 por
ciento de toda la economía rusa por sí
mismo lo hemos recortado el sistema
financiero de eeuu y hoy también estamos
bloqueando cuatro bancos más importantes
eso significa que cada bien tienen en
eeuu será congelado algunos de esos
impactos superiores se sentirán con el
tiempo a medida que impedimos el acceso
ruso a las finanzas y la tecnología para
sectores estratégicos de su economía
y si me dieron su capacidad industrial
de 100 años entre estas acciones y las
de nuestros aliados y socios estimamos
que recortaremos más de la mitad de las
importaciones de alta tecnología de
rusia la líder de la oposición
bielorrusa acusó el jueves al ex
presidente al presidente alexander
lukashenko de alta traición por permitir
que rusia atacara ucrania desde su
territorio mientras tanto lukashenko
dijo que ninguna tropa bielorrusa había
entrado en ucrania veamos el papel de
este país en el conflicto
en una reunión en minsk con sus
principales generales
alexander lukashenko no dio una
respuesta definitiva sobre si las tropas
bielorrusas se reunirían a los combates
en ucrania
lo diré de nuevo nuestras tropas no
entraron en ucrania pero si es necesario
lo harán por rusia y por belarús
unos 30.000 soldados rusos llegaron
oficialmente a belarús a principios de
este mes para realizar ejercicios
militares pero el kremlin anunció más
tarde que se quedarían más allá del
plazo de retirada y este jueves las
tropas rusas atacaron a ucrania desde el
norte
para la líder exhibida de la oposición
bielorrusa es vital antígenos acá ya
permitir la ofensiva desde su territorio
ya convierte a lukashenko en cómplice de
la guerra dijo que la independencia de
belarús se ha visto comprometida y pidió
a la comunidad internacional que imponga
sanciones al mandatario y sus aliados
lukashenko y su régimen comparten
plenamente con putin la responsabilidad
de esta guerra innecesaria e injusta
esto es alta traición y traición a los
intereses de nuestro pueblo y del estado
bielorruso
el presidente del consejo europeo pidió
el jueves a lukashenko que se abstenga
de realizar acciones militares en
ucrania mientras que el primer ministro
británico boris johnson dijo que
sancionaría a belarús por su papel en el
ataque pero es improbable que estos
requerimientos intimidan a lukashenko
que desde su disputada reelección en
2020 depende cada vez más del apoyo del
kremlin para mantenerse en el poder
hasta aquí este informativo sigan
conectados con nosotros
[Música]